I got question so we mentioned that in
response to the current
Panero crisis the key response was given
by nation states rather than
international organizations yeah so so
it's tickle it's an article is that
nowadays we have so many global
challenges and we want to make
globalizing words we need to pick them
and so fix say various problems like
climate change environmental pollution
so my question is do you think the
answer that we were the way that we can
fix this problems will be nation-states
for international organizations because
of the loop but look back at history
World Bank IMF and United Nations are or
creators about the efforts of
international community to address
crisis 50 years ago now 50 years later
we fund that this organizes these
organizations are not functioning well
so now we have new a new set of
challenges so I'm wondering 50 years
later from now on what what we have well
that's what that's a very good point but
good question my own view it you know I
wrote another book about international
questions dealing with global security
threats called containment where I argue
that we should be in the business of
strengthening international institutions
at least national international security
institutions for a lot of some of the
reasons you mentioned and also because I
think that to the extent that we have to
operate internationally to reduce global
security threat we won't be I will be
neither effective nor legitimate unless
we act through international
institutions and regional international
regional organizations so I agree with
Stiglitz in that sense that you really
need strengthened international
institutions but the realist in me says
the only way you're going to get it
is if national governments perceive it
to be in their interest to strengthen
international institutions because if
national governments don't perceive it
to be in their interest to strengthen
international institutions they're not
going to do it and at the end of the day
it's the national governments that have
the armies not the international
governments you know people talk for
instance about it not the international
institutions people I'll just give one
more example and then come to Ruta
people say oh you know the Chinese have
have got us where they want us now
because we're so dependent on Chinese
debt but it's far from clear that that
in the absence of presenting a military
threat they could actually force us to
do anything